so jonathan was just explaining there
about how he got involved when the
taliban took over
um
when the taliban took over um what were
you thinking what were the thoughts
going through your mind and how
eventually did you get into pakistan
you know it was really hard for us we
were playing football and we were
exciting we were going to a school and a
university but after taking over our
country by tolerance everything was
stopped everything was destroyed and
we were not able to play football
anymore and go to schools and
universities anymore everything was so
hard for us and we get to the pakistan
with a really hard situation and uh with
really difficulties
how did you get to the border with
pakistan
[Music]
we and our team we we're a large team a
big group and uh we get to the pakistan
border by uh two hamburglar
and uh there was also taliban there was
a hard way and a difficult way in order
to pass the border and it it it has lots
of difficulties but finally after 16
hours we passed from uh tohan border and
spaghetti
you must have been very scared at that
time what was that trip like
that was so horrible that was so scary
for us because we were all
football players and we hide over and
they they can't identify us and
we pass
border by covering up and
veering bokras
you're in buckets
yeah
okay um sabria
it must have been difficult to make the
decision
to leave your families and go as a team
and leave your country not ever knowing
when you're going to go back
yes of course because afghanistan is my
country and i
bake in this
country but it's very difficult for me
for my family
and other teams
where are your family now are they still
in afghanistan
no no no
i
i can
give my family and
bring two or three of
them family
she brings about two or three questions
from her family with her but the other
people are still in afghanistan
okay and not just what about your family
my family too i i just can bring my
sister and my brother
and the rest of my family are in
afghanistan
okay and what did it mean for you
when you saw the taliban coming to power
and you thought well i probably won't
ever be able to go to school again and i
won't ever be able to play football
again
we were so terrified we thought that
everything is finished
but
after
finding someone to help us miss khaleda
and after that the russia group we find
a hub and we came to pakistan and no we
are so happy and we are so thankful for
your help
yeah it must have been well what did it
feel like when you found out you're in
pakistan now and you found out that
you've got these visas to come to the uk
we were so happy we were so excited
and
we feel that
we can have another chance for life and
for playing football we are so happy
about this matter
and are we going to see you playing
football over here
of course
fantastic fantastic thank you so much
nadis and saria let's talk to um
jonathan now jonathan do you think that
you're going to continue your support of
the team oh without doubt um once we
come over here we're gonna have a big
party
i'm gonna take them to the best um
pakistani restaurants in up the north
because we've got great ones
and after that we're gonna um
get them into the great british way of
life we've got some universities that
want to help them we've got some premier
league clubs
that are willing to give some coaching
and the goal is for them to win some
trophies and
we're going to try and do that for them
what they didn't tell you was that
the there's only 32 girls in the team
but we managed to get i think 130 of
their family across as well because you
couldn't leave their close family there
the the taliban would have would have
seek them out so
it's a big success story frankly and a
lot of hard work